you have two kids that are on their way  to maturity yes out of the twelve which  are  two of the most important things that  you taught them from them accountability  i think it's so important the second we  all decide that somebody else's fault  for our unhappiness is the second we're  unhappy the other thing i think i think  a lot about is empathy that's why i love  that word so much i want my children to  be compassionate and empathetic to other  human beings obviously they have a very  different life than i did and they're  very blessed and it requires them to be  double compassion and pathetic and so  those are the two that stand out